want to watch this Tick Tock with you
guys these are tits no they're not guys
they just get back from him
and she wants to stick our order I said
okay I'm gonna take the bronzino and he
said I'm gonna take the burger and the
waitress asked him you want some cheese
on your burger and he asks is this gonna
be extra and she says yes it's three
dollars extra oh and he said okay then
never mind and I'm like what the actual
[__] he's like oh my God you have to pay
extra for everything these days and I'm
like yeah it's New York City I just paid
the bill and walks out of the restaurant
so I texted him the check is taken care
of he should have gotten the cheese and
I bought it
[__] stupid that's a Razor's Edge
right there man you know the anxiety she
just put on a hell of dudes now they're
like [__] I'm lactose